it's flying after you I'm not flying it
sky daddy's real sure is nice out I'm
not in Los Angeles anymore this is
Wisconsin over the years one of the
things that has helped us grow the most
as filmmakers are all the thoughts and
opinions and critiques that all of you
have given us it's been awesome reading
and learning with you guys episode 4 a
brush has just come out on go 90 the
stories really cooking now in fact one
of the biggest gunfights you've ever had
the film is in episode 4 and I would
like to ask you a favor
now because there's no YouTube comment
system over on go 90 we don't quite know
what people think please leave us a
review leave us thoughts good or bad it
doesn't matter I just want to know what
people think of the series I would
really really appreciate it there's a
link in the description now I know
internationally a lot of you aren't able
to access this yet and for that I'm
sorry
it's in the hands of the production
company to figure out how this is going
to work globally there is progress being
made and we will tell you more as soon
as we learn that's it thank you well on
one hand it's nice to have manual
control sometimes it's cool to just set
it in the air and let it just go shoot
on its own I'm going to learn to not fly
drone and let it fly itself
very frequently when you're getting
drone shots are trying to film an object
you're trying to have a global point so
to speak orbiting that's the easiest
feature before we even start dealing
with the menus fly the drone directly
over up so it knows where we are and hit
apply and now if you look up at it it's
anchored to our location in this now
orbiting around us you can fly it up and
down to a certain height distance so you
still have a lot of control over but
it's constantly going to be anchored
it's really freakin Abela now you can
make it go real fast you're on the edge
of a cliff or just somewhere cool it
does a really good job of surveying the
area it's really simple it's my favorite
one
the very portion of situation tonight it
turns out Batali's at our table and he's
going to be streaking we're sort of
captured all from our probably better
angles than most other people who aren't
expecting it
[Music]
every day man reinforce a strict dress
code and only Ren listens to us Saturday
was the streamys for the technical
Awards things like that's editing
tonight is the whole streamys award it's
mostly just a celebration but there's
like 30 more categories one of which we
won we got voted best visual and special
effects on all the internet video about
a time it's all yours
it's all yours Hunter I don't feel right
yeah next category okay that's a good
video clip no one told us that this was
going on I want more of these little
transcending men there may be a woman
transcending woman I think they are
women this shape of the bosom I want
more transcendent women on my shelf
right now we've only run in one person
which is two people Jimmy and ran
hopefully Randall's account run doesn't
count
[Music]
let's move on to the next one follow me
mode perfect
basically this next mode is really cool
because it uses the GPS data and it's
basically locking on to that data and
will follow the remote wherever you
bring it and hit apply
seven meters 8 meters 9 meters 10 meters
say Framus off and then hit apply apply
wha satellite signal to week but all
bars are full get it harder can I see
yeah go for it
ok well yeah maybe it's not working I
don't know it's a satellite signals too
weak but all the bars are full yeah I
mean I have no idea why they say that
I've literally done that up here before
so I don't know royalty-free emoji the
street girl ball Shriekers
Entertainer of the Year please welcome
to the stage the Queen and the
Chancellor of YouTube jenna Marbles and
blue
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody expected
what expected to see me here but what
about myself dick huh oh you think I'm
kidding oh boy
but it's funny because everyone's really
on the hunt right now sir team of people
swarming around us right now they didn't
see where he went through the crowd here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like on it as winners for the best
visual effects award for trainees and
posted some cool clips of us up there
but instead of Sam Gorski ego pairing
her and Jake Watson doesn't say Ren
unfortunately so let's write out now
with my phone since it seemed to have
issues with Carmichael's alright final
intent it's locked on it's flying after
you I'm not flying it sky that is real
the active track is now finally working
I'm tracking Sam right now I'm not
flying it it's literally just following
him I honestly believe it was the
overheated phone I want to do one last
cool woman my plants way ponds waypoints
are just like in video games you can set
one point here one point there it will
remember all your points and then fly
through them move it to your next
Waypoint okay the second Waypoint make
you more and that's the fourth Waypoint
it done done all right here we go let's
see what happens apply uploading
waypoints and get ready here we go
it's so thanks mark
oh it's trying to stay locked on
Oh
pretty cool right that was awesome with
waypoint mode we could probably set
shots that you can do multiple pick so
set up your waypoints set up your camera
paths and all that stuff and that way
you're not manually controlling it for
every shot very little human error one
next time we take up the training wheels
and go full power on this drone
[Applause]
ah
[Music]